il ya un groupe qui commence à prendre
forme mais c'est pas d'aujourd'hui
et puis ça élimine un tout petit peu
toutes les injustices que nous avons
eues depuis pas mal de temps
des critiques qui sont pas toujours très
honnête vis-à-vis de ses joueurs qui
méritent qu'on leur donne confiance
qu'on leur fasse confiance
une grande équipe ça se bat dit pas
comme ça on un coup de pouce soit un
coût d'écriture il faut travailler il
faut sans cesse donner aux joueurs la
possibilité de croire alors alors alors
moyens je crois que ce soit ils ont bien
répondu
on peut peut-être faire des plus grands
shows si on nous laisse encore un tout
petit peu de temps dernière question
c'était vraiment un commando vous aviez
soit il n'y a pas de commandos c'est du
football football
nous avons une équipe de jeu c'est
depuis pas mal de temps
d'ailleurs depuis le match aller contre
la roumanie il ya une éthique de jeunes
ligne directrice une logique de
sélection et tout passe et les joueurs à
derb énormément bravo